[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rosen the
executive director here at long now
hopefully most of you didn't have to go
to SF Gia's before getting rerouted he
how many people went to SF Jazz tonight
all right yeah so it's really great to
be back here at the herps they've
renovated it if you haven't checked out
the murals they're extra awesome now a
couple announcements as you know now the
entire back catalogue of the videos of
these talks are available on our website
and we have a new iPad app to help you
enjoy them so please do check that out
also I yeah works also on Apple TV also
on October 4th we're having our first
member summit and so any of you are
there any members here nice so yeah on
October 4th we're going to the content
that we have been generating for you
it's now your turn to generate content
for us and so we're gonna we've been
working with Brady Forrest at ignite to
do a series of ignite talks so please
check your email there's a link there
where you can submit your ideas for
ignite talks 5-minute talks or the 20
slides cycle through at 15 seconds each
it's pretty it's a really great way to
get a lot of ideas out fast so submit
your ideas for talks and we'll be
curating those and then we'll also just
have kind of an unconference style
format where people can sign up for
topics and tables and really start to
get to know each other which we know
many of you from around the country as
well as just in this area just from
judging how many people really want to
hang out after these talks and and talk
to each other we really want to provide
a venue for that so please check that
out
and tonight's long short a short film
that exemplifies long term thinking was
suggested by Kevin and
these that you will campaign if you
remember from from 1993 was both
prophetic prophetically right and
prophetically wrong at the same time so
don't blink this is only a 30-second
spot but it gives you an idea of what
the inevitable was in 1993
have you ever borrowed a book from
thousands of miles away across the
country
[Music]
without stopping for directions
[Music]
or sent someone a fax
from the beach
and the company that'll bring it to you
AT&T thank you stir brands from a long
now foundation a reminder on these
question cards Kevin Kelly is not
filtering the questions tonight Kevin
Kelly isn't answering the questions
tonight so Alexander Rose will be
peering at these things in the dark in
the front row trying to read them
legibility counts and briefness counts
that's what gets to the stage and I'm up
here reading them trying to listen to
Kevin at the same time and short and
readable is good what happens if you
apply the long term thinking to
fast-moving digital technology the
answer is Kevin Kelley
[Music]
good evening so I wanted to talk a
little bit about where technology is
going and a lot of what is coming is
really not at all predictable but
there's a certain aspect that is and I
wanted to dwell on that I think that
there is a tilt to technology that comes
from the fact that these are physical
systems and that there's a bias in the
way that the circuits and electrical
wires and chips work and that bias makes
reoccurring patterns and these patterns
form a general direction into things and
we can look at these long term
directions which are in some senses
inevitable but the particulars are not
the specifics are not so we would have a
kind of large form like a quadruped ed
that is inevitable in biology and in
mechanical world but the specific zebra
is not the the particular species is not
as you can think of this as sort of
almost like rain falling on a valley
coming down in the path of a particular
drop as it goes down the valley towards
a river that pathway is that all not
predictable it's inherently random but
the general direction is inevitable
which is downward and that kind of a
gravity that pull is what I'm talking
about
and and then so we could say in a
certain sense that they're large forms
of telephones were inevitable but the
iPhone was not or that the internet was
inevitable but Twitter was not so there
are 12 of these kind of trends that
they've kind of managed to bring
together but they're kind of braided
into each other and those forms or could
be the second in many different ways so
the twelve are kind of arbitrary in some
in some fashion or another and I want to
talk about them because they're all kind
of interdependent on each other they
feed each other they're kind of
self-supporting and so I wanted to talk
about those twelve as quickly as I can
because there's 12 of them
first one is is becoming and becoming is
the general state that we're all in
right now we're all moving from
something to something else we're
becoming something and that has now been
applied to the technological world as
well and so the large form shift that
we've seen in the past couple decades is
this movement from solid things physical
things tangible things nouns that are
being made soft that they're being
there's a move to the D materialized
world that there's the world of the soft
the world of verbs the world of process
and so we're moving from products to
services and that's that's been a
general shift and that shift to this new
world where things are kind of liquid
this liquidity is actually something
that shapes everything and in some ways
and forms all these other trends that
I'm talking about so we have we have
things that are flowing we have the
ability to decentralize things because
they're kind of liquid we have the sense
that things are always in moving in flux
and so that's the general trend that
we're all in a certain sense in this new
liquid environment where we're biology
and technology is much softer more
organic so to speak much more like a
fluid than before and that means that in
certain sense that all of us have to
become newbies perpetual newbies because
we're always being upgraded
we ourselves have to keep upgrading
we're always having to learn and unlearn
and relearn and that's the permanent
state that we're in so this sense in
which all the things that we're making
or in some sense is becoming is
something that will inform these other
trends I'm talking about I think the
most important of these twelve that I'm
talking about now is a something I
called cognate I that's the word that's
an archaic word that means to make
smarter and it's because we don't have
any other good words for that likes
martini or and to smarten pie so to
cognate I means to make smarter it's
make things more intelligent to bring to
the world of
the hard this liquidity of smartness to
to make them more like something that
learns something that that's something
that changes in an in in a very orderly
way and so we already course have this
we kind of know it also as artificial
intelligence it's now president working
behind the back room going through
x-rays diagnosing them better than a
human doctor could going through legal
evidence better than a human peril or
could and flying our planes when you fly
long distance of the human pilots only
flying for seven or eight minutes the
rest of time the AI is flying and in our
cars if you have a modern car today you
have a little tiny AI chip in the brakes
which is braking better than you are
that's what we have right now that's
there we don't think of it as AI because
generally these are things that AI is
basically something we defined is that
what we want to do and once we can do it
it's called machine learning or
something else we now have the example
of alphago from Google beating the
world's best go master so we had a sense
in which this is not just brute force
there's something creative here and
recently Google was teaching its AI deep
mind to learn how to play video games if
you're playing a video games these days
you're playing against the AI half the
time but they taught how to learn how to
play a video game which is profoundly
different they taught it they by showing
you the game and it learned how to play
so this meta level of learning how to
learn is profoundly different it's
artificial smartness is artificial
learning and I call it may be artificial
smartness because intelligence has a lot
of baggage around it to color artificial
intelligence we mean lots of different
things by it but artificial smartness is
something we understand your calculator
is smarter than you are in the
arithmetic
GPS unit is smarter than you are now in
spatial navigation Google is smarter
than you are in long-term recall and so
the point about those kinds of smartness
is that they're not human like they're
not like they don't think like the way
we think and so the reason why we want
to put AI into a self-driving car is
because it's not driving like us it's
not being distracted about worrying
about whether it left the stove on it's
it's only engineered to really focus on
driving and so it's an inhuman like kind
of intelligence and it doesn't have
consciousness I'm not talking about that
in fact they may the fact that it
doesn't have consciousness is sort of
its benefit we actually may advertise
these things as consciousness free okay
because that is actually something you
don't want in a lot of a is the point is
is that our own intelligence has a very
poor understanding of what intelligence
is we think of intelligence as this as
IQ which is just a one single dimension
as a single vector a single growing
loudness and you start with something
that's very small like an intelligent IQ
of a mouse of a chimpanzee of a not very
smart person of like average person like
myself and then a genius and that this
is getting louder and louder but in fact
this is completely wrong our own
intelligence is much more like a
symphony of different notes played on
different instruments and each of those
instruments of cognition is a different
type of thinking there's deductive
reasoning
there's spatial reasoning there's
emotional intelligence there's all these
different varieties of intelligences
which are composed and compromising
aggregated into what we call human
intelligence and that course can vary
from person to person that makes it a
little different and then in the animals
of course it's a similar case well they
have a mixed and they may not have as
many they may have some fewer but in
some cases those particular notes
instruments are actually may exceed ours
and loudness they may be louder than
ours in certain dimensions a squirrel
actually has a long term memory that
exceeds ours because it has to remember
where it buries all those nuts and so
when we engineer the
chances and machines we're also going to
do likewise where we're going to create
many new instruments and we're going to
gradually add more and more of them but
some of those instruments will again
exceed us in particular dimensions and
those are the things that we are going
to use them for because they are greater
than us in certain dimensions and
because they think differently than us
so it's really kind of a misnomer to say
something is smarter than humans because
what does that mean it depends on what
dimensions you're talking about I think
we're going to undergo a Copernican
revolution in the idea of intelligence
which we imagine right now is serve our
intelligence which is mistakenly called
a general-purpose intelligence we
believe is kind of there with universal
general problem-solving intelligence and
around us or all these other satellite
kind of intelligences but in fact we
don't have a general-purpose
intelligence our intelligence is very
very specific it was evolved for our
needs as humanoids on this planet and I
think once you begin to populate all the
different kinds of intelligences our our
will realize that there are many maybe a
million different ways of thinking maybe
hundreds of thousands of different kinds
of minds that we could make artificially
and all these different kinds of minds
will in fact perform different functions
in fact there may be some problems in
business and science that are so
difficult for us as humans to solve they
may exceed our capacity as humans to
solve them we may have to solve them
with a two-step process where we invent
a kind of a mind that can work with us
to solve those problems I think in the
long term what we discover is that out
in the scallop sea of all possible Minds
we're way out on the edge we're not at
the center we're at the edge we have a
very peculiar distinctive kind of
intelligence in our job right now in the
next century even is to find and
discover and invent as many different
kinds of thinking as possible so I think
of these as alien intelligences because
their job is to think differently so the
second thing about this cognate I is
that it's going to birth basically the
second industry
revolution the first Industrial
Revolution was enabled I would argue by
something I would call artificial power
which is an ability to take fossil fuels
and steam engines and to make a power
that far exceeded our ability to use our
muscles and animal muscles so anything
built in the agriculture area era had to
be built with human animal muscle that
little is very limiting now with
artificial power we could make highway
skyscrapers railways factories churning
out endless roads refrigerators that's
all been enabled because of artificial
power and when you drive down the road
in your your car you're harnessing
effectively 250 horses with the flick of
a wrist okay that's the power that we
have available and we can actually
distribute that power on an electric
grid so that every home farmstead
factory had access to this power and it
was utility a commodity that anybody
could purchase just by plugging
something in so even a farmer on a
homestead could have a great wild idea
where you could take something and you
could Electrify it you could take like a
manual water pump and then instead of
using human muscles to pump water hey
we'll add electricity to it will
Electrify it and then you have the
electric pump and you multiply that by a
thousand a hundred thousand a million
times and that's the Industrial
Revolution that's what it was all about
was this this huge explosion that we
could make all these things that
surround us that we could never have
done with our own muscles and that speed
and scope and scale was now available to
anybody who wanted to purchase
electrical commodity so now we're gonna
do the same thing we're gonna take that
electric pump and we're gonna add
artificial mine order force intelligence
artificial smartness to it and we're
gonna have smart pumps and we're gonna
multiply that by a thousand a million
times and that's this new era where we
can take intelligence so in addition to
the hunt 250 horses that you have in
your car you're now you're going to add
250 minds to it and that 250 minds in
250 horse
that is a self-driving car that's the
robocar as it goes across and so we can
imagine like what would you do if you
could have a thousand Minds at your
disposal 24 hours a day seven days a
week all the time doing something and so
this IQ this this AI is when it's flow
across the cloud in a grid it's gonna
become a commodity a utility and anybody
could purchase this AI to do what they
wanted to do just like you can purchase
electricity okay and so for me the
formula for the next 10,000 startups is
very easy take X add a I take take the
most unlikely thing you could possibly
imagine and they add AI to it take like
taxicabs at AI uber okay so the more the
more unlikely I think the more the more
powerful that transformation is going to
be so today right this minute right now
right after we're done you can log on to
Google and you can actually purchase
some of Google's AI it's for sale
six cents 100 hits it's doing these
things like being able to you can query
it ask what color the ball is what color
dress does a girl have on it'll answer
so that's available to anybody right now
and when this happens as this is
happening there's a concern about our
work and what we will do when Gary
Kasparov the World Chess Champion lost
to deep blue the reigning supercomputer
at that time he realized that he was at
a disadvantage because he did not have
access to the same database of every
chess move as deep blue did so he
started a chess league where you could
play any style he wanted - including
playing with AI and he called that
Centaurus where you were working next
with a eyes in robots and today the best
chess players in the world are not a
eyes they're not humans they're the team
the center of a is humans and the best
doctor dargah machines in the world are
not Watson
sir in AI nor a doctor it's the team of
doctors plus AI so we're gonna be
basically paid by how well we work with
a is next to them again they're their
intelligence will be complimentary in
many ways to ours and so I think the way
I would suggest that we enter is to
understand that we're going to be
working with these things not rather
than against them
so that's cognate I this third trend the
third force is interacting and basically
if things are not interacting we
consider them broke in these days so we
want and we crave and we're moving
towards increase increasing interaction
with the things that we make and the
ultimate I think is in sense of where
we're using gestures or whole bodies in
the way that the Tom Cruise character
and the merit and Minority Report was
conducting data it was no longer just
his fingertips there's no longer
interacting in a limited way it was this
entire body and of course we saw that in
Iron Man as well but there's lots of
little nano radar chips that can
actually read micro gestures on our
fingers and then there's the ultimate in
Direction VR this is me on the rights in
1989 was jaren when you're trying out
virtual reality and I really believed at
that time it was really amazing and
transformative I thought it was going to
happen in five years I was wrong but it
was it was really good and the problem
was simply that that year cost the
equivalent of a million dollars today
and what's happened in between that time
and now the the technology is not that
much better but smartphones have made it
three orders of magnitude cheaper so the
technology for the VR is the three major
components are actually embedded in a
smartphone and when they became
commodities the location and tracking
the gyroscopes
the tiny screens which are now in your
eyepieces and the video processing that
that has now been borrowed by the VR and
now you can have something that's almost
at the consumer level and if
now good enough to improve the thing
about VRS is that it will become I think
the next platform after smartphones and
there's two kinds just to kind of clue
you in there's the immersive type which
is where you put the goggles on it
completely closes you and you're in
another world and then there's the mixed
version the mixed reality where you have
a clear spectacle in looking around and
you see inserted into the vision of the
room or outside of the office these
virtual objects or virtual people that's
called mixed reality and mixed reality
is actually the more technologically
challenging to do if you can do a mixed
reality you can actually do virtual
reality just by painting the glass black
okay and so if you can do one mixed
reality can do the other and mixed
reality is has tremendous potential in
terms of Education where you're
understanding how a heart works maybe
you're making designing virtual objects
you can actually walk around and and
handle on or you can have virtual
screens and this is Microsoft's vision
where you are populating your cubicle
with as many screens as you want and
also virtual colleagues of course we now
know what augmented reality looks like
we can see that we don't even need
goggles in a certain sense we can
actually use a 3d positioning of the
phone and so there's going to be many
varieties of this idea of mixing in
taking the digital world and the
physical world and embedding the two
together and that's a great example of
sort of where we're going with that and
the other thing that we've discovered is
not just how you see 50% of the
experience is coming from your hands
your ears your skin the other parts of
your body is it's a tactile thing we
believe in reality not just because what
we see because of what we feel and what
this happens and this was a surprise to
me as I was trying this out is that when
you're in these things you actually feel
something you you the the assemblage of
the sense that you have something real
in front of you or that your
you'll place it's not happening in the
front of your brain it's happening much
deeper behind it deeper in your brain
and that when you leave you have the
sense of not having seen something but
having felt something having experienced
something and so I think it moves the
currency of the internet from this world
of an Internet of information and
knowledge to this to this Internet of
experiences where the experiences become
the currency and and and it's not just
dangerous experiences that you couldn't
have by yourself but it's it's the idea
that there are some experiences like the
presence of somebody next to you in in a
hospital or seeing a demo right in front
of you and being able to to move your
hands around to feel it these things
change the nature of how we know things
and that's the that's what we're getting
with it's virtual reality is not the
fact that it's looks real if the fact
that actually feels real to us and I
think that in a sense because when we
have virtual presences I was able to try
some telepresence --is where actually I
felt as if that person was there even
though until actually knew they could
not be and so I think VR is going to
become one of the most social of all the
social media it's it's not I mean we're
gonna spend a lot of time hanging out
sharing experiences downloading
experiences creating experiences with
other people and we'll be shocked by how
how social this is that telepresence is
is something that I'm willing to pay for
and I think who's gonna be coming fairly
soon
where you're not just seeing a person
like they see on skype but you actually
feel as if that person's there and that
really enables a whole level of
communication that we don't have right
now so the social aspect I think is
going to be huge the fourth trend I
think the fourth force is is this move
that once we have this liquidity that
flowing of things that we can actually
change the nature of how we think we
possess them so this was noted by
someone else but they noted that uber is
the largest
taxi cab company in the world does not
own any cars Facebook is the world's
largest media company it doesn't own any
content Alibaba is the world's largest
retailer doesn't own any inventory and
Airbnb is a world's largest lodging
company and owns no real estate so
there's something happening about this
nature of ownership and I think what's
happening is is that oftentimes if
things are liquidity and liquid enough
if they've can flow fast and immediately
then having access to them can often be
better than owning them because owning
has a whole bunch of responsibilities
that are often overwhelming the benefits
and so we've moved into an arena where
almost very few people buy movies
anymore or buy music or buy books or
games if you have access to all of them
anytime you want it and part of it is
having the access to all that's
necessary and anytime you want is also
very fundamental but there's a general
drift in that direction where the
benefits of being able to access things
Trump's the benefits of owning them and
the other advantage of actually seeing
what was formerly a product like a car
as a service you have access to like
transportation is that there are many
more ways to turn something into a
service than there is to make it into a
product that there's sort of a greater
fungibility a greater diversity in the
ways in which we can turn things into
something that you access rather than
just something you purchase and so as we
think about transportation
uber is only one there's five or ten
other variations where you could have
you could drive people's cars instead of
having them drive you you could pull
them up you could you could reverse to
have a reverse auction for of getting
the ride so there are there are many
other alternatives that are enabled by
the fact that we made something into
this service that you access and that's
of course is the demand economy it is is
that your
an infinite number of possibilities to
take something and tried to see about
what would happen if you moved it from a
product into a service so sharing is
something we know about I don't want to
say too much about it because it's we're
filled with it we're surrounded by talk
about it but there's several things I
wanted to suggest about this a notion
that we are increasing the amount of
stuff that we share over time and if we
looked into 30 years into the future we
can imagine us sharing more and more and
more what I think is that we're still we
didn't hit peak sharing yet we're still
at the beginning of the sharing meter in
terms of the amount of things that we're
going to share the reasons we're gonna
share and the ways that we're going to
share it and when I say sharing what I
really mean is collaborating it's
cooperating that's that's the value and
that's what this technology is bringing
to us we're inventing new ways to
collaborate and cooperate at levels and
speeds and in dimensions that were never
before possible if you think about
Facebook 1.5 billion participants yes
they're just sharing photos and and and
gossip but it's the fact that you have
1.5 billion people collaborating it's
some on something together and that's
was simply not possible before and will
go further from that and so when we talk
about sharing it's not just about this
idea of like swapping things it's the
idea that we're making tools that enable
us to cooperate and collaborate in ways
that we simply could not before and
cooperation is really the whole stepping
stone of civilization and human and
human innovation in progress it was just
increasing the ways in which we can
cooperate increasing the complexity so I
would say anything that we can imagine
that can be collaborated on and
cooperating and that's what we're gonna
do it will be as we go forward and part
of the opportunity that people have is
to think about ways in which you could
harness eight billion people to do
something big and long now maybe do
something that took a long time more
than a generation to do or we wanted to
do it really fast or we want to do it in
dimensions that we don't
and think about right now so this
collaboration on a planetary scale is I
think where we're moving to
in this sharing dimension and I have to
mention a blockchain which is a very
complicated thing to explain it means
simply that you have a shared ledger a
shared way of doing accounting that's
not centralized and there are many many
things that we could do with that in
terms of doing contracts in terms of
doing business in terms of distributing
trust that was not possible and I only
highlight that as a single example of
ways in which we're going to figure out
how we can share and collaborate and
even distribute think things like trust
that we had never been able to do before
and and that's where we're going with
this increasing sharing so um screening
you know we have a big screen right here
there's little screens in everybody's
pockets if you fly there's a screen on
the back of every seat
there's even in China especially there's
buildings have been turned into screens
at night and even during the day Times
Square I think in the goodness of time
almost every flat surface that we make
will eventually be covered with some
kind of screen because it may be as
cheap as paint and there is flexible
screens in particularly in the getting
thinner and so when people talk about
like an e-book we normally think of for
something like a Kindle a flat plank but
in fact there's no reason why you
couldn't have an e-book that was made up
of thin pages each of those pages was a
screen and that you bound them together
into leather binding that was really
beautiful and after you finished reading
the book you would thump it on your
thigh and it would turn into another
bucket so you still have all the
highly-evolved navigations that we would
have from a printed book but they're in
a eBook so there's nothing to say that
screens have to be flat and rigid they
can be on our clothes they could be
even floating in air but the point is is
that we are moving to the screen and
every screen that we look at is looking
back at us okay so it's looking at the
some of the Samsung Galaxy I think sixes
have returned camera that looking at
your eye gaze they can tell where you're
looking which then can transfer into
like a heat map of say a website or a
movie or whatever you are staring at and
it's telling you where your attention is
in fact we can even go further there's a
couple companies that have software that
can detect your emotion to these 26 or
24 hour emotions and they can tell
whether you're distracted whether you're
perplexed whether you're frightened
whether you're engaged whether you're
bored and they can adjust the content to
that in many many ways and so it's it's
like a it's like talking to a person a
little bit in the sense that you're
having a conversation you're changing
what you say depending on their reaction
it's it's - is two-way its
conversational and so these screens
again will interact with us by looking
back at us and they will be part of this
larger movement where we have been
people of the book the Western culture
was basically centered on text so we had
the Constitution we had the Bible we had
books of law and so this this centering
on authors and the same route as
Authority was the foundation of
basically Western civilization it has
produced an incredible blossoming of
great stuff but now we were moving away
from being people of the book to
becoming people of the screen and the
screen has a wholly different dynamic
it's this liquidity it's this thing
where the informations flittering across
as pixels they their never-ending
streams they're just in ephemeral
they're that they're not fixed works are
not finished like Wikipedia they are
ongoing everything has to be upgraded
there is a sense in which
things are not closed and they're
open-ended and there's all these
dimensions where we've again have moved
from the fixed precision and the
authority of a book and so we when we
want to know what was true we went to a
book we went to authority and now we
were people of the screen and we have
screens and things are fluid and they're
messy and and the relativistic and
they're open and they're subjective and
so when we try to find out what's true
it's actually a much different process
and we have to in some ways assemble the
truth ourselves we have to we have to
have a networked idea of truth where any
fact is you have to so right now the
problem on the internet for every fact
there's a counter fact for every expert
there's a counter experts for every bit
of information there's some anti
information and so we have to understand
the truth is something that's more
networked and that you can depend on it
because there's other nodes they're all
set themselves depending on other nodes
that are reliable because they're
depending on other nodes are reliable
and so there's a very different way of
assembling truth and that's one of the
many consequences that we have from
moving from the authority of books to
the fluidity of screens so and as you
see part of that is the fact that flows
everything is flowing more and more and
we're kind of in the Third Age of the
computing metaphor so the first one was
you know with a desktop and and
everything was modeled after the office
and so we had files and file folders and
and the desktop and and then we moved to
the second one which is forget that we
have we'll have the web we'll have pages
and links and this whole thing is this
is spidery amorphous with no edges and
that's and that's the model that we
understood that but now we're moving
into the Third Age
this third metaphor and that's the
streams and the flows and so we have
Facebook streams and streams of music
and we have Netflix streams and we've
got the streams across the news banners
and we've got update streams and
everything is streaming across and
everything's in ephemeral there serves
this is a flow and things are flowing
and data is flowing and that's the
metaphor the regime that we're in now
and so that flowing is also what flows
is data and so data is forever flowing
and that those flows of data is the new
model and that only will increase in
this liquid world if everything is
flowing if all of all this data is going
then we're gonna track it I think
anything that can be tracked will be
tracked and that's so scary
and I want to refer back to the virtual
reality virtual Minh
a surveillance device that we purchase
and carry around voluntarily then VR
worlds are total surveillance states
that we're gonna enter into by ourselves
okay because in order to actually do
they are all your emotions have to be
tracked and the more sophisticated these
VR worlds are reading your
micro-expressions so that your avatar in
there has the same micro-expressions
which is what they're doing right now
your total gestures movements so that
you have this sign language and you can
move things around and your avatar has
the same body language they ought to be
captured and if they're captured they're
tracked and so right now the VR
companies are not doing much with that
data except trying to make your avatar
but eventually they will and so these
are totally surveilled world and the
kind of tracking that would be very
expensive to do in a real world it's
gonna be very cheap and easy and
inevitably done in the virtual world so
just to give you a heads up that's where
we're going and I was involved with
starting a movement called the
quantified self where we were looking at
how people would track themselves not
just for health reasons but for
productivity reasons for memories for
[Music]
for many reasons the Apple watch is one
example of a kind of now commercial
quantified self device but the idea is
is that you would as these sensors would
get cheaper and cheaper you would fill
your world your daily life with these
kinds of tracking and we would be able
to track anything that could be tracked
in that somewhere today someone is
tracking anything that can be tracked
this has not yet reached the mainstream
but the potential benefits are immense
even for health what you really want to
have is kind of a life log where you are
tracking all your bio particulars or all
the important things about your biology
and your health for all of your life so
that you would have a normalization you
would know what your normal was because
it turns out that our normals are not
the same your normals now my normal my
normal changes depending on time of day
time of year the season of life and we
had we and all by the way all our body
lis functions are all signatures they're
all uniquely identifiable including your
heartbeat and so we can capture all this
and we can use that for many things but
among them is this dream of a
personalized medicine if you actually
know what your normal is you can
actually formulate a therapy a treatment
that's really specific to you and you
know several people have ideas about how
that would be done the important thing
is is as done by us tracking ourselves
but of course it's not just us tracking
ourselves we're being tracked by our
friends we're tagging us on Facebook
we're being tracked by companies as we
voluntarily surrender our information
and where we are with Pokemon that's all
being tracked and I think it's
inevitable that we're gonna be tracking
more and more I see almost no counter
force to the fact that in 50 years from
now we will be tracking more of our
lives so I think that's pretty
inevitable but what's not inevitable is
how we shape it the particulars I
suggest as
it's stance of covalence as one way to
domesticate this tracking and that
covalence means is that we are tracking
the trackers we watch who watches us
that there's rather we turn something
that's asymmetrical where they are
tracking me I don't know what they're
tracking I don't know what they're doing
with it I don't know if it's correct I
don't know whose are sharing with I
can't correct it or hold them
accountable and I get no benefits that
is very very very uncomfortable to us
but the other version of that where I
know who's tracking me I am tracking
them I know what they do with
information I know whether it was
corrupt I can correct it I can hold him
accountable and I get some direct
benefit we are familiar with that
because we've evolved for a hundred
thousand if not a million years just in
that state we evolved in very small
groups of people work we knew everything
about each other so that we know how to
do what we want to do is then is restore
some of that symmetry to this tracking
so that we can if the cops are gonna
film us which I think they should we
should be filming the cops
we should have access to that all both
sides and so that sense in which we
restore some of the covalence were were
mutually surveilling each other we're
mutually tracking each other is really
to me the way that we can actually make
this inevitable tracking more civilized
and the second thing I would say about
that is that there is a a coupling
between to two dimensions of this
tracking and the data there's one
dimension and I would say it's it's
simply a axis where I went in there's
your your private and you know your
private on the other end you're
transparent I guess it's on your screen
it's the other way around so transparent
and private and so but but that that
that that axis of whether you are
revealing everything about yourself or
not is actually coupled to another axis
and that's the axis
of personalisation engineer so at one
end is you are being treated as a number
your there's nothing known about you
you're just an average thing you have
nothing unique about you and so you get
the treatment of just being a number of
the other end is is that you are being
personalized and you are being treated
as a very unique individual with your
wants your desires your genetic makeup
your background your history the whole
thing and so I want people to treat me
as an individual I want I want my
friends to know about me treat me as
individual I want companies to treat me
as individual I want my government the
treat me is individual to be aware of my
situation to to to treat me as
individual and in order to do that you
basically have to reveal yourself in
some capacity the reason why you have
friends is you've revealed yourself to
them they know you as an individual if
you don't want to and I think we should
have a choice about this slider then
you're going to be treated in a generic
way and so the thing is that these two
are a couple so if you want to maximize
personalization then you kind of have to
maximally maximize transparency if
you're if you're happy and prefer to be
private in that sense of not known then
you have to accept a generic treatment
and here's the thing that we didn't know
about ourselves is that when we give
people that choice to move the slider
with technology they always push it to
that side to the personalization to the
transparency side and so the the way I
flippantly summarizes is that vanity
Trump's privacy okay who knows so that's
something we didn't know about ourselves
but that seems to be the where we're
going now we may change your mind later
on when we see the price of it but I
think where we're going is is is that
the wreath there's a reason why we are
tracking allow a lot of the tracking is
that we get some benefits from that and
those benefits are basically
the personalization so we mixing is
another long-term drive trend and that
has to do with the fact that when things
become liquid when they become digital
they are now able to be reduced and
unbundled into their native elements
their native parts and then they can be
recombined so if you think of something
like a newspaper a newspaper was
actually a very complex product that
actually had many different components
headlines obituaries sports scores news
stories classified ads book reviews
there was a ton of things into it and
when they became digital people could
basically unraveled them and unbundle
them into Craigslist that took all the
they classified and someone else took
called the headlines or the sports
scores or the gossip and each of those
became something into itself that was
added to other primitives and then
remixed and then later on they were
themselves were unbundled and that's not
just true for newspapers you could kind
of unbundle unbundle all the things that
a banked it once you made it more
fungible and liquid you would say well
the bank is doing many things it has
loans is giving interest is forming
mortgages and so those could all be
unbundled and you can even do it with
cars in the sense that there's aspects
of cars cars as the product cars as a
service that could be unbundled and
generally what's happen is is that we're
going to we're kind of coming down to to
the elements it's like if you want to do
chemistry the best thing to do is to
understand that everything is an element
and be able to reduce things to an
element that you could then recombine
two different compounds and that's sort
of what we're doing with this digital
era is is that we're understanding that
every product and every services in some
ways a complex remix in a recombination
and that this digital technology allows
us to reduce things to their primitive
element and then recombine them and
recombination actually turns out to be
the central engine of technological
progress I mean the progress based on
technology the wealth based on
technology
to economist Brian author and Paul Romer
um independently and separately have
their own theories about how most of the
advances in technological society come
from nothing venting new things but
recombining the old things in many
different ways and that when you try to
make a formula or I should say a model
of the economy of a modern economy the
only way you can account for the fact
that it grows is is the fact that you
can kind of recombine existing things so
the growth that we see in the two
hundred years the economic growth is
fundamentally due to the fact that we're
recombining these and what's happened is
that the digitalization has accelerated
the ability to reduce things to their
elemental primitives and then to
recombine them in many many many ways
and that will only continue into the
future anything that can be unbundling
anything can be rebuttal filtering is
the other aspect of this which is that
we are making so many things so many new
things that actually exceeds our ability
to pay attention to them and where ever
attention flows that's where money goes
the took a long time for people to
understand that all the attention that
was going to the internet was would be
where the money went but that's what's
happening it's going away from TV and
other things towards the internet
because that's where the attention is
and so we are dealing with the fact that
we have an intention economy and it's
remarkable that we give our away our
attention for nothing to watch to watch
a an advertisement and I am suggesting
that one of the disruptions I could see
coming is that we might actually start
to charge for our attention charge to
watch an ad charge to read someone's
email and that when that does is that
you kind of changes the dynamics and
takes out the the advertising agencies
and other middle people and you have
this you have the possibility of kind of
a peer to peer whereas what you're doing
is you're going to use the influence
maps to kind of identify people that
have a lot of influence and
they may not be necessarily people who
are rich or people who are famous they
actually could be a girl somewhere who
has lots of followers who are following
her fashion trend and she has tremendous
influence and they would be actually
giving her the marketing money directly
so that she would influence those rather
than going through this idea of
advertising your your serve your
distributing and appear to peer way that
influence and you also could pay people
to create ads and they could be rewarded
as those ads went virally and and so
they're not going to make ads for
fortune 500 companies but like Google
Adsense they make make ads for people
who right now could never afford to make
an ad like mom-and-pop Chinese
restaurant or something you could have
people making ads and those ads went
virally and you would get credit back if
someone clicked on it or watch it so you
could have a way in which you distribute
it virally all the ads then they were
also being paid the people who made this
ads so this is I'm very briefly giving
you an idea of the way in which even
advertising could be decentralized and
made more liquid and distributed with
this technology just an example of how
we're managing our attention and how
we're using these filters to to manage
them the second to last one is
questioning and you know there's a lot
of I think if you want an answer today
you ask a machine right you you go to
the machines to answer questions it used
to be very very expensive to get
anything done I it it's very hard for us
to even imagine remember 20 years ago if
we're that old thirty years ago for that
old what life was like when there was no
internet you and you had to go to a
library to ask a question it was most
questions were never asked because it
could not be answered now answers are
free and what's becoming more valuable
or questions because every every time
you you ask a question you get an answer
every answer serve generates prompts to
new questions and if you if you map that
out if we if we figure that we're
actually in
creasing the number of questions
exponentially but if every answer
generates two new questions then you
have something where the questions are
being generated faster than the answers
and so basically what we're doing is
we're expanding ignorance okay but I
think that's actually a good thing
I think that's an actually good thing
because it's in ignorance ignorance is
opportunity ignorant is often profit
ignorant is where we're going to live in
this world of much more uncertainty
because we're going faster and faster
and I think what happens is that while
answers become cheaper and cheaper a
good question becomes more and more
difficult more and more important more
and more productive and machines are
really good at answers and humans are
going to be really good at questions for
a very long time and I think figuring
out and being taught how to ask a good
question is really going to be what
education is about and I think learning
the art of questioning is sort of what
science is about its what innovation is
about it's a way of a what if what if we
did what if we try this that those are
all questioning explorations the kind of
a question what happens what's down here
where does this go and so these kinds of
things where efficiency is no longer
important and we have something that's
much more open-ended not as efficient
not as certain that's where we're going
to be living so good questions a good
question something that generates not
only a good answer but even more and
better questions so it's recursive a
little bit like that I think we're just
at the beginning of where we're going I
think that's word just at the very very
start of the first hour of day one I
think when people look back to now 2016
they'll be they'll be amazed that we
thought we had the internet now because
compared to where we're going we don't
even have it I think the web which is
one of the biggest I think in retrospect
will be seen as one of the greatest
inventions that we've made and in in the
last half century was not even invented
30 years ago
that's that's a new thing social media
is less than 2,000 days
we're just weird we're just we're just
really at the beginning of all this and
there are no experts in AI or VR or
attention technology we there's lots of
billions of dollars being spent on AI
there's lots of very smart people
working on it but compared to where
we'll be in 30 years there are no
experts VR is the same thing we have no
idea how VR works we have no idea what
will work in terms of telling a story in
VR we're just really really clueless
right now in 30 years we'll realize that
there are no experts so so we're at this
kind of a stage right now where we if we
think about the next 25 years or so into
say 2040 and the people will look back
now though they'll realize though
actually I think they're gonna be very
envious about us now because they'll
realise that that we're at this moment
when there's never been easier to do
something and yet there were all these
tremendous opportunities ahead of us of
a I take X and a day I know virtual
reality is completely unknown you you
all the easy things to find a right
before us and we're gonna find them in
the next 10 years there's just an
incredible opportunity that's opening up
and not just us in in this audience but
around the world and that opportunity is
is all before us and so they though I
think they're gonna be envious that they
said only if I was alive and well back
in 2016 what I could have done so I
think that the in that world of 2040
that the greatest products of that error
that the ones that will be really
dominating their lives haven't even been
invented yet
today it's they don't exist so that
means that you're not wait so thank you
[Applause]
not lazy
yeah by the way you're right on your
time try hey long-term thinker 10,000
years what's this about 30 years I think
I there was something that I think I
coined called the Moscow rope the moths
goro point which is that middle-aged
people tend to imagine a future that
will happen before they die uh-huh and
so so that maybe part of it is is that
maybe I'm interested in trying to
describe something that I could possibly
live to but not beyond because it's sort
of outside of my experience so younger
folks here get to do 50 or 60 years yeah
do that okay as I recall you keep track
of your actuarial - yes when do you plan
to die
so so I actually have a little thing on
my my computer right at the top and it's
a countdown clock to my expiration date
and it's it's it I went to the actuarial
tables and looked up the statistical
likelihood of of how long I would live
based on someone born when I was born
and where I live and then I turned that
into a number of days and I set that
into the clock and so it's counting down
and it was five thousand seven hundred
and seventy days left and so what is
that what year was that will it be oh
that was I think that was I think it was
72 uh-huh about what you're you planning
to die oh okay well so that's
I don't know I haven't figured out the
number but but the point is taking it
down day by day not year by year though
it's by day by day so I know how many
days and so that's very very focusing
for me it's because I have five thousand
seven hundred days to do all the stuff
that I need to do and want to do and
that's not very many days of course if I
live longer then that's all bonus that's
all gravy right but still who knows and
so I'm living I'm counting I'm not
counting those days I'm trying to
maximize those days and yet you're not
frantic no but I think I should be it's
just somehow encouraged being relaxed
about things that you're not sort of
worrying and wondering you've got a date
service schedule accordingly yeah I I
think I think it's just you know it's
just a reminder of your own mortality I
think it's good to to have before you
and I think it's really good when I get
an invitation to do something I can look
at that clock right know some questions
and eally s will say I want to own or
access human intelligence is I think you
know looking at sir what's the
interaction coming between they are IQ
and these others yeah it's it's it's a
it's it's a it's a common worry I think
there's I think I think it's a the
possibility is something we shouldn't
it's more than zero but I think it's
unlikely and I think it's because I it's
I I think some of these kinds of things
would be even very hard to program into
it and there was if you gave someone the
assignment to do that it would actually
be very very difficult to achieve and I
think it's even harder for it to it kind
of happen on its own so I I think
there's not much reason for us to want
that to happen and and therefore because
we're still engineering these things
there will be difficult for it to happen
on its own you think our own
intelligence will as it has before
adapted
technologies and so what we call human
intelligence will actually be itself
quite different yes I think that's much
more likely is that we change our own
intelligences over time because because
we've been changing our bodies over time
already so you and I are manufactured
beings we invented humanity we invented
ourselves the reason why we have this
tension with technology is because we
are both the Masters and the slaves we
are both we created humanity and then of
course we are they created we are the
creators we shape we make the tools the
tools shape us and that's inescapable
that's in the that's in the very basic
nature of humanity is that we will
always have that tension in another
thousand years will still be wrestling
with the fact that we are both masters
of this technology in it and we are
slaves to it at the same time and so
that that will never go away and I think
that's cause a lot of our own concerns
and hand-wringing and worry about
technology is that that we're caught in
that in that tooth to face aspect of it
is is that we're both the parent and the
child at the same time
well there's Kotnis is interesting it's
in your book you say that you used to
upgrade as late as you could yeah
because of the nuisance factor of
upgrading but then the nuisance factor
grew of not upgrading right and so it's
this becoming a situation for basically
all humanity that nobody gets to opt out
yeah do we all have to upgrade mm-hmm
yeah so uh the last speaker along now
speaker on the stage was George Dyson
and I thought he had a really great
dichotomy which is that one of the
central decisions that we have before us
is do we remain one species or many and
so there's a view on well I mean I think
if mandatory upgrade is part of the the
prospect of humanity I think there's a
whole Amish contingent that's gonna say
it under no way is me or my descendants
ever going to
to modify our jeans or whatever and so
you have you have a separation well
they're very selective they use the web
and write to questions that kind of
relate ELISA asks what does the
dominance of access ownership mean for
artists and David gross off asks what's
your advice to new and future librarians
of Congress and so on capture organize
all this kind of information how the
libraries change how the artist changes
yeah the the prospect of ownership I
mean I I skated over there very fast
because there are some benefits to
ownership that maybe will make it worth
for some people and of course if we're
using things somebody has to own it so
you can't have a world where there's no
ownership at all so I think in the
intellectual property I think the idea
of owning ideas is problematic and I
think the idea of even owning data is
problematic because it's very intangible
so I would like to see a second version
a second another attempt a tree
visioning what an intellectual a real
intellectual property system would be
based around and the intangibles like
ideas and data because I because I think
we're very far from it and it's and we
don't have a good understanding of it
and so the issues of copyright or baked
into that but I do I do think that this
shift is is will will have an effect on
our idea of capitalism which is founded
on the idea of ownership and even our
status of wealth what we consider well
we often attribute to people who own
lots of stuff and if they were out of
economics is based on scarcity and we're
talking about floods right exactly so
you have this you have economics around
abundance and access rather than
ownership that that can change how we
view how things work Kirstin be a sort
of the mean opposing forces you see
impeding the forces you outline so these
twelve big driving forces grinding away
yeah what are the twelve big don't you
go there forces yeah so I I'll get to
that but one thing I will say is I I'm
by temperament very optimistic and I
don't talk a lot about the the downsides
of the negatives and and I would say
several things about it one is that
every the more powerful of technology is
the more powerfully it can be abused so
powerful technologies like AI will be
abused but there will be a criminal
underside to these there will be people
using these for harm but what's
interesting to me is that even those
those uses will follow the same general
trends and meaning that these these
drives is these gravities these forces
apply to even when we are abusing him
and using him for harm okay so that's
one thing the question about what could
stop these things what's the counter
force that can derail them I think
fundamentally like if Moore's law
stopped I think that would have a huge
impact
if this relentless doubling of power and
halving of cost every 18 months was to
stop if we were to run out of that I
think that would have a huge effect on
the continuation of these trends because
we got to taking that rate of change at
constant exactly it's an assumption it's
built into this I mean it would be and
may I mean we would be like stupefied if
if computers actually started to get
more expensive and slower every year
right and so that's quite a concept well
later that unnamed person asked what
about the future are you actually
worried about yeah it's a little
different than counterforce it is it is
and I'm not worried about the the robots
taking over and killing us but I am
worried about other more near term
aspects of artificial intelligence and
there's there's several what one is I
think there's a bunch of groups right
now working on trying to put ethics into
AI systems particularly its self-driving
cars so most of the car companies have
groups that are trying to decide that
and it turns out that in order to
program a self-driving car to have the
right Essex and the kinds of problems
they have is you're driving down the
it's driving me on the road there's a
crash and it has to swerve one way or
the other if it serves this way it it
protects the passenger of a surge this
way
hits pedestrians and so or vice versa
and and so the point is we have to make
that decision now and so nor that's an
ethical decision it doesn't really have
a right answer but we have to kind of
figure out what the answer is and in
order for us to program in our ethics
and morality is we have to have a very
clear understanding of them and we don't
we actually have very loose vague
inconsistent shallow ethics and so in
order to do that we actually have to get
better at ourselves and I think in the
long run the AIS will teach us as we try
to teach then we will learn how to be
better ethically but that's a challenge
that we have is is actually not
conveying it but actually figuring out
what our ethics are what our morality
czar and then the second place of that
and we're a little worried about that is
is that I I wonder if we have a world in
which there are beings that have any
kind of embodiment that that are serving
us whether treating them if we would
treat them as slaves whether or not
they're slaves or not just treating them
as could be corrosive to us to our
spirit and so I I don't have an answer
but I but that is something that I worry
about is whether we would have we would
have all these things and if you've seen
the videos of the Boston Dynamics robots
the four-legged robots that I showed up
there people kicking them as a way to
show that they're stable we cringe at
that because we feel that and so we
might we may have feelings for these
things that might there might affect us
in ways that we're not really ready for
us so I worry a little bit about that -
well society sort of learns by mistakes
and catastrophes what ones do you see in
this thirty years that you're looking at
might occur that would be so educational
if they don't just give us in
iiiiii I think we're at a very dangerous
place with cyber war and and they eyes
military militarization of AI because we
have no rules we have a whole set of
rules Geneva Convention about ordinary
war it's kind of weird but we have these
rules about what's so trade when nuclear
war first came along right and then
Herman Kahn had to do thinking about the
unthinkable and that was the beginning
of applying right math and rules to
nuclear war and we don't have that right
now we don't have what we have any
consensus of what's acceptable is it
okay to take out the banking system of
another country is that permissible or
is it okay to disrupt the you know the
trains is it okay to disrupt you know
maybe just something like the traffic
lights you know we don't have any kind
of a sense of what's acceptable what's
not and right now the US Russia China
Iran Israel or are conducting cyber war
they're not talking about it because
nobody knows the rules but there
actually are is conducting defensive
offensive attacks and I think there may
be some disaster of dam being broken or
in a lot of civilians dying before it
may take that you actually have people
decide well okay that's that's not okay
you can't do that and we will I mean
being able to verify these things are
very difficult so there has to be a
whole whole procedure for for being able
to verify that this nation state is not
doing that
I think we're nowhere near that and and
and I my worry is that it will take a
big disaster before the forces are
brought on to make that happen that's
kind of international agreements or you
know something like the internet
engineering those sorts that stuff out I
think we need a world government a hush
see a little more about that yeah I
think if you have planetary problems you
need a planetary governance government I
think we have not just global climate
issues we have immigration issues these
are beyond these are planetary scales we
need to have you know like even like the
recent South Seas
you know tussle China like that that's
that's an island on an island it's you
know so it's like the there we're at the
point where any any other civilization
in the galaxy would have a world
government okay and so and so you know
Star Trek right so that's why we need it
it's it's it's I think it's an idea that
nobody at left likes nobody in their
right likes but I think it's a good idea
and and I think that I have no idea how
that's possible what interests me is is
that how is it even possible to have a
representative democracy for 8 billion
people
what's the mechanics of that does that
even there's a even conceivable what
would how would that possibly work so I
have no idea how to do it other than I
think that we do need it and I think it
would be really helpful in tackling some
of the biggest problems we have well I'm
gonna Majan if sort of the best efforts
that the nation is in these various
entities UN and so on mate in relation
to climate change don't add up to
actually solving the problem that's some
kind of that would force the kind of
governance entity that you're talking
about right your first book was pretty
biological out of control and this book
is severely digital and there's a
Moore's law of biotech going on that
some say is faster than Moore's law and
more profound they're not just talking
about the code of communication and
computation the code of life
so you know the biotech stuff how do you
think it relates to what you see going
on in these digital trends that's that's
a really good question because I should
have made a caveat in the beginning that
it my my book and this talk was really
focused on the digital not on the not on
the biological matter energy not on many
other futures that are that are very
important and how the the digital will
impact well well the kinds of things
that by the way you are tracking very
well and using current genetic
techniques I think would also severely
suffer if it wasn't for Moore's law my
name is Moore's law stopped all that
kind of progress that we see the
biologic realm would also halt and so I
think they're tied in a sense that it's
it's not that there's the same system
but the tools that we're using the tools
not only of discovery and manipulation
but again for me the tools are of
collaboration the tool that makes the
science work that the tools of peer
review and an exchange of information
all those things are very instrumental
in learning because because we are
changing how we know things we're
changing how we discover things and
those are the the meta tools that are
that are mostly being propelled by the
digital world so the biological
mysteries abound and are profound we
don't know how the brain works exactly
we don't know how our microbiome works
we don't how the immune system works and
we care deeply in terms of health and
everything else and the code that's
running all of that is the world's worst
spaghetti code and so try and reverse
engineer it it's not it's just you know
deep learning data mining yeah yeah and
is is that actually working I mean you
know shotgun sequencing was way to
finally be able to get the human genome
and then ancient genomes and so on is
that kind of understanding of these
previously unknowable but profoundly
important to us in all of life systems
is that gonna be opening up with these
trends do you think III do think I mean
going back to the spaghetti code in our
own brains I think that what I think one
of a is artificial intelligence major
roles in the next 20 or 30 years will be
as a probe to understand what our own
brains do not by opening them up but by
trying to model them trying to replicate
them in other words the III this is what
I call the third way of knowledge so
there's the humanities which kind of
figure out how things are by by looking
at human expression by going in inside
themselves by doing what artists do and
then there's a scientist
the second way the scientists who do who
run experiments into probe by by trial
and error
then there's the third group which is
the Nerds technology technologists and
the nerd way is that you investigate
something by trying to make something
new so the way that you investigate
intelligence is not to probe it not to
to think about it but actually to try to
make an artificial intelligence the way
you study reality is not by any kind of
experiments by trying to make a virtual
reality the way that you study democracy
is to make a virtual democracy so it
says there's this the way the way in
which you try and and and in probe the
the the basis of this state of being is
through making something so that learn
by making is the third way and I think
that is what AI and and and even the
role in biology would be which is as a
as a scope as a scope to figure out when
telogen is by by trying to make it that
many different ways as possible so the
maker movement is
also with us it's right exactly it's
actually the third culture it's actually
the third way of knowing it's actually
the third and varying growing a very
important way in which we actually you
render the human condition which is by
making things and so it's it's a force
for for knowledge for for progress it's
not just people you know in the basement
with 3d printers is way beyond that this
is such a Whole Earth Catalog kind of
Owen asks 30 years from now what is the
role of nature any so um I added the
Afeni yeah right I I take the the
proposition that some others share which
is that the nature of nature in the wild
today on this planet is that every
single acre of it has been affected by
humans already so it's been altered so
so it's already and a gardened state of
nature and that what we will will
continue to do that will continue to to
affect it will continue to bring it
together with the the digital the
technological realm in some ways so it's
it's like we're domesticating it and so
that wildness is long long been
transformed it's just something that we
have a hand in and we'll have more of a
hand in and I think that we'll use it to
to make it serve both us and the other
species and so it's not I think we want
to serve all the living species on the
planet
and to bring some of them back and add
more of them and that that is something
that we can actually do and so I think
the relationship that technology has to
nature is is in some ways at this point
is to not harm it further and to make it
more compatible with our own
civilization so I so I so I think it is
something that III see technology's a
seventh kingdom of life that actually
has derived from evolution when the same
powers and so it's not antagonistic to
life inherently that is inherently
compatible then any we there's no
invention that we we haven't been able
to make greener in a certain sense so we
can continue to green our technology to
make it even more compatible with the
biological world I also let stuff play
out in terms of cities yeah I'm
repeating Stuart here and I think that
urbanization in concentrating people
into cities it's actually one of the
best things we can do for for the for
the green the while the nature part of
it and and I see cities as cities army
are the most complex technology that
we've made even beyond computers that
that they are basically a technological
invention that we're gonna continue to
make them improve them better that will
move more people into them and that this
digital technology will make them more
biological in a certain sense you know
the advances like all the driven cars
and smart materials all have promised to
help us manage this technology of
urbanization which will increase and
then I think pilot for these you know
the early thought was well everybody's
just gonna go to a beach somewhere and
be online and that's that that didn't
work out yeah because I think what we
get in cities is opportunities and
possibilities and we crave those almost
over anything else in the density gives
you that just the access to a lot of
strange people or what yeah that that's
and and the fact that that we have more
technology and technology gives us more
choice
so there's more technology if there's
more people and both of those together
create more choices and that's what
draws people to the city I don't think
it's necessarily the bright lights it's
the fact that they have choices they did
not have back in their beautiful organic
Gardens in the beautiful hillsides with
their strong families they came because
they actually thought that having more
choices was more important than those
very beautiful things
now you travel Asia and the places you
travel in Asia are often the places that
are the most sort of traditional and
ancient and the old village life and so
on do you see that eroding because of
all this and do you agree for how do you
see that yes it is there the villages of
Asia are emptying out and they're you
know they're leaving behind certain
traditions and they're they're getting
new ones I'm I am compulsively
documenting what they're leaving not
with any nostalgia and because I
understand why they're going and I would
if I was in their shoes I would go to
but I am documenting it because it's
going to be gone and there's there is
there there is a beauty to it I mean
there is a beauty to a house that's made
out of bamboo sitting there on stilts I
would not want to live in it nobody
wants to live in it it's drafty is cold
I mean it looks beautiful and it would
go away everybody there would much
prefer to live in a concrete box as
waterproof and and and and tight and
warm it has running water and so but
they are leaving those and so I so I
appreciate what it is that they lost but
they're moving there because they have
more choices they have the choice of
education for the children they have the
choice of medical care that they don't
have in the village a freakin education
here it has a question may be useful
beginning toward the last one what is
the inevitable for education schools in
the Universities yeah you know home
training like you did yeah what are
these things doing to education um I
actually came away from my experiments
with
virtual-reality kind of impressed that
that had a huge potential to teach us in
a slightly different way again because
you seem to be at least I seem to be
experiencing things in a different part
of my brain and I think when you are
moving things with your hands and they
feel real that that burns different
circuits than just looking at them on a
screen and I think being able to learn
particularly some people learn you know
much better that way and I think that's
potentially valuable not just for
mechanical skills but even conceptual
things that when you have that kind of a
3d and you have an you have a feeling
you have you have a whole body involved
I think you can learn differently we can
learn how to maybe teach things that
seem very conceptual right now and
intellectual maybe even that way so I so
that's one thing that I think is is is
going to be used I I think the thing
about this inevitable in education is
that we will become lifelong learners
that's that's the that's the thing is is
that it you are gonna need and will be
taught the skills of how to learn and
keep learning because there will be no
alternative really that you just have to
you're gonna be lifelong learners since
the hopefully that's the skill that you
learn and that a lot of it won't take
place in school I'm very impressed with
the kind of training that the military
does the way corporations do it is
phenomenal
when they you know they train for
results and they get them and so maybe a
lot of what you're learning is not going
to be in school and we kind of know that
so so I think what's inevitable is just
that that that learning how to learn
critical thinking are going to be the
things that you learn at school so how
does generations play out maybe moving
in on this because young come into a
world which is you know we've got a lot
of these trends going on and it used to
be
you know they had to grow up before they
got to really master the tools are out
there now it's the old farts that cannot
function I mean I can't type with my
thumbs and so I'm totally limited our
young going to be increasingly sort of
advantaged in this you are not late
they're really not late they've got so
much stuff not to have to unlearn in
order to function
yeah I I would suspect so I mean I think
you could make a scenario where the
youth of the world have an advantage I
mean and you think cohorts are
identifying themselves more I mean sort
of each new tech sharing check that
comes along sort of the you know the two
years later gang and high school have
they're not using Facebook they're using
something else so you're like oh you're
still using a faithful here yeah exactly
yeah and obviously that's yeah you know
if all these trends continue that's
gonna continue so each cohort has its
own sort of version of the digital world
that distinguishes them which is great
then that they start to own the world
but it also separates them and our
friend Bruce Sterling wrote this
wonderful book holy fire where basically
people get to start living really long
and then medicine gets to the point
where you can take your long life and
actually swap it yourself back into a
young body and but then the question is
can you keep up with the young who are
actually young and his answer is no do
you see this kind of issue I don't see
it in 30 years
III think well at last no me not me I
mean I I think most like we walk out
into the city in 30 years from now this
city other cities it's gonna be
predominantly the same most of the stuff
most of technology that we're
surrounding here right now is old stuff
old moves very slowly you
you have the layers and most of our
brains are very old brain its reptilian
mammal there's a very thin layer of
human consciousness on top but most of
our thinking is is old and I think most
of the technology that will continue to
be old and that the Industrial
Revolution was about atoms and it
rearranged our world but that's done I
think the rearrangements that we'll have
even in 30 years it's not going to be
fast changes in the cityscape it's going
to be in the intangible world and their
understanding of how we're connected of
who we are what does it mean to be human
how we spend our day and so it's it's
that flow so we're gonna rearrange the
flows of things not the atoms I think
you're gonna be pretty much the same so
that when we walk out in 30 years from
now it'll be look like the city but
we'll have a different idea of what a
city is well different idea of who we
are we'll different idea of how we
relate to other people so the new stuff
keeps coming but you say the old stuff
doesn't go well doesn't go away and that
continuity is what gives us a shot
exactly that's what old people will
always have a role thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you